[Music]
you are one of the og women rappers I
grew up listening to you what do you
make of cardi B and Nicki Minaj party is
that girl I don't know the other one
party is my girl and so I'm so excited
for my girl cardi I can't wait for her
to have the baby I love you Connie
that's Lil Kim throwing a little shade
as she hit the carpet for the launch of
Paris Hilton's new clothing line talk
about being here I know that you and
Paris Hilton go way back you known each
other every year that's one of my good
good girlfriends like every time you get
together it's always fun yeah and the
thing is it like we never forget all the
fun we had like we get together I like
do you remember like no I don't remember
exactly the moment we laugh as soon as
we see each other what are the chances
that she's gonna hop up on stage with
you tonight during your performance wash
you she better she always does so it's
like it when we're together and I'm
performing it's like the night is not
right if she does in popcorn stage I
don't know who know this but it's been
about 17 years since Lady Marmalade came
out I know we were a baby babies like I
mean you're not considering I came into
industry at 17 so it's like people I'm
like a childhood star to people like I
was like so it's like now you see me as
a woman with the baby for me it's like
wow what would it take to get you and
Mya
and Missy and pink and Christina in the
studio again I would like to say one
phone call take one phone call and
scheduling because we're all still
really good friends we still love each
other all of us like you know a lot of
times when you have success in a group
or with a record a lot of times the
girls aren't like speaking or either you
know ones like in contact with each
other where we always all of us always
speak your daughter just turned four
for Cena's daughter is about to turn
four
you guys have playdates with you what
happened that's the one thing we haven't
done and every time we see each other
like we've got to get the kids together
than me at least you know I have it yet
I know what you do for your daughter's
birthday did you do anything we went to
the Sugar Factory
she loves candy cotton candy big
lollipops like she had such a great time
you see any musicality in her yet yeah
she's always trying to sing dance every
single time you and before I let you go
I spoke to Tyler Henry recently last
year I guess so love him you guys have
the best conversation any love there was
like a project where you had unreleased
Big E music of song sorry I got some
stuff coming and I'm working on my album
I got a new single coming really soon
like sooner than you think yeah maybe by
the time that you walk out of here you
might it might and I'm just go I have to
get everybody around but really soon
[Music]
[Applause]